Republican Senator Jim Scott of the
beautiful state of South Carolina his
book opportunity knocks is out
I've recommended highly to anyone who
needs to be inspired about growing up on
the wrong side of the tracks and still
making something of your life I think
that is an understatement in the
senator's case senator good to have you
thank you for coming Thank You Neil
absolutely it's good to be with you
again hope you're well same same here
you too what do you make of this
these Obama comments obviously you know
his conversations on a phone call picked
up that he is echoing something we've
heard from others that the guess is
Democrats who say the administration's
response has been weak here now not all
Democrats because others like the
California governor talked about how the
president has delivered for his state
but but this is going to be a theme no
doubt that's going to come up in the
doctor foul deed testimony with some of
your Democratic colleagues maybe some of
your Republican ones what do you think
yeah no doubt I would say that the
former president's comments were
unhelpful unnecessary and unfortunate
the truth is when you're in the middle
of a pandemic a global pandemic that the
world has never seen before let's focus
on all hands on deck pushing in the same
direction we need to get our economy
back open at the same time we need to
continue to flatten this curve and to
reinvest in testing testing testing and
if the comments are not heading in that
direction then we're having a
conversation that should be delayed
until after we are beyond this pandemic
or at least on the tail end of the
pandemic and we're not there yet we have
a lot of work that needs to be done we
need every single mind focusing on how
to a keep Americans healthy and B
reignite this economy because that for
unfortunately will lead to even more
deaths than we have predicted so far you
know you talk about the economy senator
and I heart getting back to your book
opportunity knocks you talked about the
disparities you know in various groups
and I was thinking about
african-americans and the progress that
have been made dramatically reducing
their unemployment rates and getting
more jobs it's now reversing itself in
light of the shutdown in the economy
it's unavoidable but but those rates are
going up at a faster those on a point
rates are going up at a faster rate than
they are for whites does that concern
you well I think any unemployment
concerns me I mean think about it this
way Hispanics were around 4.2 percent in
February and April they're almost 20%
African Americans were around 5.2 5.3%
February early March and now we're at
eighteen point seven percent
White's have seen their numbers double
or triple and agents have done the same
thing lower but yet we're still seeing
that what that tells us a couple things
number one if you are on the lower end
of the economic totem pole you typically
have jobs that require you to go to work
and some of those jobs it requires you
to go to work I in the retail sector the
restaurant sector and in the hotel
sector those three have been devastated
and so if we're going to get those
numbers coming back down we've got to
focus our attention on consumer
confidence to go into retail stores to
go into restaurants and to do business
travel and leisure travel that includes
hotels so I think this is this is a
temporary shift in the numbers but for
us to get it back we have to realize
that the American economy is driven by
confidence it's an intangible thing that
becomes tangible in our activities we
haven't seen that yet so the country and
the states can reopen the the
restaurants and the hotel rooms and and
the retail outlets but unless we have
confidence from the American people they
won't show up which means that that
stagnant unemployment rate that has been
around for four or five weeks will not
get better quickly that's bad news for
the economy it's worse news for
America's health and we're gonna have to
tackle that and those are some of the
questions I will direct towards dr.
Falchi in the same way that I did last
week tours dr. Collins we have a chance
to reshape this recovery reshape the
health crisis by having more tests on
demand and by using some of the latest
technologies something called CRISPR
which is as close to a genetic knife as
you get we've got some tools at our
disposal that I'm pretty excited about
from a from a
scientific perspectives that may
actually help us to flatten the curve
and maybe even see it have a sharp
decline over the next several weeks as
we have more tests in the marketplace we
are we are heading in the right
direction we're getting there faster
than we were just two or three weeks ago
you know there are a lot of people who
have criticized the president for being
in this rush to reopen the economy
without addressing the concerns of
medical personnel on this report that
the White House buried a CDC study that
looked at ways you go about this and
some of the things in precautionary
measures you should take I don't know
where you stand on that but among some
of the recommendations they wanted were
a lot more aggressive than the stuff
we're seeing now do you know anything
about that and do you think the
administration is rushing this I don't
think the administration is rushing it I
think what we have to do is to take a
look at our reigniting the economy from
a panoramic perspective and then we have
to go from the macro to the micro said
differently there are parts of the
American economy in places like South
and North Dakota where you have low
density it allows you to have a faster
opening and frankly a faster recovery my
former colleague governor gnome of South
Dakota has already been able to move
forward because she her state has not
been negatively impacted states like
South Carolina where we've had some
impact we can move very quickly forward
as long as we do it with a methodical
progressive of step forward towards
reopening no one's rushing at this point
at least in South Carolina and the
states that I've studied around the
country are well watching very closely
senator good singing again be well be
safe